más de un año de pandemia pero tan solo
100 días de vacunación en américa
latina'
esta cifra redonda se alcanzó en un
momento crítico para la región en medio
de retrasos en la distribución de
vacunas y cuando varios de sus países
están inmersos en plena tercera ola de
la pandemia
el reciente aumento de casos está
desbordando a los hospitales de varios
países por ejemplo las tasas de
ocupación de las ucis superan el 80 por
ciento en todos los estados brasileños
excepto en dos versiones straits el país
mejor situado en la carrera por la
inmunización es chile que se sitúa entre
los tres primeros del mundo en tasas de
vacunación
la paradoja chilena se aprecia sin
embargo en el alto número de contagios
de las últimas semanas tras la
flexibilización de las restricciones
ayer viernes el país sumó 8.000 nuevos
casos y el pasado jueves se decretó el
cierre de sus fronteras la vacuna se
transforma en una alternativa de salida
a este gran problema pero también se
transforma en la causa de otro problema
es decir esta comunicación
triunfalista respecto de que somos el
país que más rápido acuna que somos
felicitado internacionalmente mandó una
señal a las personas respecto de un
cierto relajo pero la situación más
crítica de la región la vive sin duda
brasil actualmente es el segundo país
del mundo en número de contagios y
fallecidos por corona virus y muchos de
sus estados se encuentran en estado
crítico con las ucis colapsadas y sin
espacio en los cementerios la vacuna
para muchos es un alivio
ciertamente es un alivio si dios quiere
hay una vacuna para todos lo antes
posible porque mis hijos aún deben
vacunarse
colombia por su parte cumplirá apenas
dos meses de vacunación el próximo 17 de
abril criticado por su lento proceso
actualmente ha inoculado a más de 2
millones de personas